La Llorona supersized.
Yeah.
She’s already scary
on the regular screen,
She's gonna be...
She's gonna be even more intense.
I can’t even stand her back there.
When you think of La Llorona,
you think of hearing her.
Weeping.
Yeah. Weeping.
You know there’ve been sightings
of La Llorona…
We’ve touched La Llorona…
But, really, sound
is the most important thing.
The bathtub scene.
Yeah.
The floor scene.
The door scene.
Especially to frighten an audience.
Yeah.
Just hearing something
before you ever see it.
It is frightening.
And that’s also why you should go see it
in a movie theatre.
I think that’s why horror…
An IMAX theatre.
Yeah, it definitely accentuates all the scares.